Stress is a part of life, and it's not always a bad part of life.
Most of us enjoy good stress in small doses...
...like roller coasters, watching sports or even a scary movie.
That's the kind of stress that keeps us young and on our toes.
Then there's bad stress, or worse, chronic stress.
Negative stress isn't just in your head, it can affect us both mentally and physically.
Stress hormones in the body for extended periods of time can physically age our cells.
So when you're stressed at work or home, your cells look and act older,...
...making you look older and even impacting your immune system.
Not only does it add years to your appearance, it can also affect your memory,...
...making brain cells shrink permanently.
Even short-term stress can make it hard for you to remember simple things.
The good news is, you can manage stress now...
...to prevent more damage to your body and mind tomorrow.
Stress management is a skill that can be learned.